no no no a cólera en las calles de parís
estos franceses exigen un aumento de las
pensiones y los salarios insuficientes
para enfrentar el alza creciente de los
precios en especial de la alimentación y
el combustible una realidad que corroe
su calidad de vida y que las
estadísticas traducen en un incremento
de la inflación de 4.5 por ciento
interanual en marzo un récord en el
actual lustro la pérdida de poder
adquisitivo es una motivación electoral
fundamental para los franceses y los
candidatos a la presidencia lanzan sus
anzuelos entre sus promesas de campaña
la mayoría de los aspirantes de
izquierda propone aumentos de entre 120
y 230 euros al actual salario mínimo y
tanto la derecha como la izquierda echan
mano a una jugosa promesa la reducción
de impuestos de llegar a la presidencia
anne hidalgo marine lepén y valérie
pécresse disminuirían los que pesan
sobre la electricidad y el combustible y
ya han hinchado reduciría a aquellos
sobre los ingresos
jean-luc mélenchon eliminaría los
concernientes a bienes de primera
necesidad
eriksen moore recortaría en más de 25%
las contribuciones a la seguridad social
para quienes tengan bajos ingresos
mientras emanuel disminuiría los
impuestos a la industria y la
agricultura y pondría fin a las
contribuciones de las empresas sobre el
valor agregado la revalorización del
poder adquisitivo pasa también por el
acceso a la vivienda que mantiene en
tensión a miles de familias y algunos
candidatos proponen limitar el aumento
de los alquileres varios aspirantes a la
presidencia macrón entre ellos proponen
aumentar la edad de jubilación a 65 años
otros mantenerla en 62 y algunos como
lepe o me leen son bajarla a 60 en el
quinquenio que termina el poder
adquisitivo de los hogares de clase
media y alta aumento en 7 por ciento
pero los hogares más pobres apenas
sobrepasó el 1 por ciento un asunto tan
sensible como la economía doméstica será
determinante en la decisión final de los
electores franceses en especial en el
actual contexto macroeconómico y
energético de gran incertidumbre por la
guerra en ucrania